duro al revés para Britney griners en el
tribunal de Moscú la justicia rusa
rechazó la apelación de las
basquetbolistas estadounidense y
reafirmó la condena de 9 años que recayó
sobre ella por los cargos de Posesión y
contrabando de drogas los comentarios
nuestros comentarios no cambian esto
ciertamente contradice casi toda la
práctica judicial existente que
conocemos en este sentido
no estamos involucrados en ninguna
negociación no conocemos los detalles
por lo que no tenemos comentarios sobre
un canjet el caso tiene repercusión
internacional y es un asunto que no pasa
desapercibido para Washington ante la
decisión de los magistrados moscovitas
la reacción llegó a través de la
encargada de negocios de la embajada
estadounidense en Moscú Elizabeth
la corte de apelaciones hizo una leve
reducción de su sentencia por el tiempo
cumplido en prisión preventiva pero por
lo demás no modificó la excesiva y
desproporcionada sentencia de 9 años la
señorita griner compareció por video en
el juicio por lo que no se nos permitió
comunicarnos con
la defensa de la estadounidense había
solicitado la absolución O al menos una
reducción de pena teniendo en cuenta que
la jugadora se consideró culpable de los
cargos elevados por la fiscalía
llevo aquí casi ocho meses y las
personas con delitos más graves han
recibido menos de lo que me dieron a mí
una resolución positiva para griner se
perfila remota en un momento donde las
tensiones entre Estados Unidos y Rusia
escalan la posibilidad de realizar un
intercambio de prisioneros está
paralizada después de que no prosperaran
las negociaciones semanas atrás